foreign
my intention is to stop after about two
and a half hours uh perhaps about half
12 if there is a natural break about
that time I wouldn't want to stop in the
middle of
a motion uh I
propose a half an hour
uh lump lunch break and so we would
resume
30 minutes after whenever we adjourn
uh um Council Fluker
as a matter of welfare I mean a half an
hour hardly gives unless of course lunch
luncheon's being provided by the council
which it's done in the past but a half
an hour does not give members time to go
to the High Street and collect their
lunch and bring it back here and eat it
okay that's a that's a fair point uh I
know I know uh some members have bought
sustenance in with them uh I'll extend
that to an hour uh
okay members happy with that an hour's
break yeah
thank you
um I think
um I'll ask Mr Dodson to explain uh
perhaps how he's going to handle uh the
this morning's events uh Mr Dodson
thank you chair
um yes there are a number of motions as
members know and the detail on many of
them is operational
um whilst they are valid motions we feel
these operational matters
um need to be dealt with by the staff
who manage those service areas so we
have a number of Staff here here today
to come and give that detail and make
sure that the members have all of the
background so there will be some quite
lengthy
um officer responses to some of these
but I think that's
appropriate to make sure that all of the
information that that's required is
shared to inform the member debate so so
that would be the um the format that
we're following
and also I think there are a number of
motions to which rule 9 May apply
because they relate to to
individual offices or identifiable posts
within the structure so I would request
through you chairman that that we move
those ones to the to the end so that we
could go into confidential and deal with
with the others first Richard do you
know the the numbers of of those ones
for us to to deal with thank you Chen
um Mr Holmes can we have how many and
what they are please uh chairman yes so
10A motion one we believe rule nine
would apply to that motion itself
yes bear with me I'm just working
through my agenda
uh 10d motion three We Believe rule 9
applies to that
foreign
motion seven
so it's it's Motion One motion three and
motion seven yes
oh I see yeah
okay
um so uh
my intention therefore would be to leave
these motions to the end of the meeting
um right so the first first one
therefore is uh rule nine one
uh so
cancer stamp chairman um would you allow
me just to say how disappointed I am
that the number of counselors have been
able to attend this meeting maybe
motions haven't been always taken in the
spirit that they're often submitted to
this Council and and I think it's a real
shame I understand the reason you gave
for actually having this meeting at 10
o'clock in the morning
um but let's hope it's not going to be a
precedence otherwise everybody who works
were excluding to actually be elected
chairman and I know you're going to stop
me but I I want to express I want thank
you chairman I want to express my
displeasure that we've got 30 15. we've
got more than half the camera only just
chairman only just chairs only just and
the thing is we've got valuable members
that aren't present who could contribute
to this thank you
I think I I understand
that as I explained right at the start
this is I'm
and although
we did discuss the possibility of doing
this at the agenda meeting it took the
CLT
uh quite a time to be able to arrange
today's meeting which is why the notice
got shorter which I am sorry for but the
intention was to give more notice it is
not it will not be a precedent but it is
an unprecedented number of motions
um at County and I don't want to uh
dwell on County matters
motions are not allowed on budget day
so it might be as you as chairman of PGA
might like to go away and look at how to
do how to deal with the surfeit of
motions
all right okay leader
uh thank you chairman yes well I've
already raised that point with officers
actually and it is something perhaps
could go through council Mrs stamps
committee and indeed perhaps
consideration being given
um as like um County it has a defined
numbers of motions that can be put
County do it on a sort of
proportionality regarding I think the
parties on there are not necessarily
advocating that but then it has does
have the Motions as being I believe time
limited and a certain time of for each
motion to be heard so I'm just thinking
um that might be something we ought to
give consideration to and bearing in
mind PGA has the Constitution I think
that could be something that Council of
flemingham and councilor stamp may want
to give thought
okay yeah do you want to respond to that
yeah yeah um I welcome the leaders um
input we're not County we're a district
council and also the leader is well
aware that since I was elected chairman
of PG a I have asked constantly asked
for meetings with the leader and the
other chairs of the other Committees of
how to take this Council forward we've
had one so I'm more than happy to look
at this but I'd rather that this didn't
um start to um to go to some I can't say
the word that comes to mind match with
the leader but I'm more than happy to
try and take it forward in my role if I
am chairman of PG a following May thank
you certainly it certainly does need
some uh management rules
um uh on on this um account County do it
I think on a on a Time basis
uh uh but then outstanding motions are
moved automatically to the next meeting
um we couldn't because we're evening
meetings of two and a half three hours
we we couldn't actually do a Time basis
perhaps it wouldn't be practicable on
such a short uh uh meeting but that
would be up to your committee to
um to find an answer to that uh right
members can we
sorry motion too uh can we move on to
motion two
um who was the proposer
councilor Lagan uh would you like to set
your motion I certainly would uh
chairman um the Motions I'm actually
mentioned it's about the restrictions
isn't it I don't want to get the wrong
one yeah
the motion to council is that the
council removes all restrictions on
public access to meetings in the chamber
and if there are more members of the
public attend and cannot be accommodated
in the chamber then the norley room is
made available for them to view the
meeting on the screen that's been done
in the past this is to be made in
accordance with the requirements of
equality act and access requirements and
any applicable health and safety
requirements
therefore I propose this motion to
council
um I I if I didn't say I um I will
repeat that I will accept all motions as
being duly moved and seconded
um so
um is there an officer response uh Mr
Dodson point of order
um chairman ordinarily under under the
rule of procedures for
um I think it's four
um three chairman I think that you have
to inform Council whether you are going
to hear the motion here and now or refer
it to committee and that has to be done
in consultation with the leader so could
you just confirm that is the case that
is the case thank you very much
um uh Mr Dodson
sorry chairman uh yes uh oh sorry Mister
thank you thank you have Mrs Green here
this morning uh who will uh take this
this motion for the officers thank you
um Mr gear
was it did you say this is great Mrs
Green uh sorry Mrs Green
thank you chairman um so I am going to
be taking members through this
um or the council's response to this
motion
um I have um to my side Mr bakerini
who's our health and safety specialist
he'll be here to assist with any queries
that
um the council may have
so the background to the the current
assessment that we have of occupancy
goes back to February 2022 when this
matter was last considered by members
um
and at that time the area that was
designated for the public had a total
area of six square meters affording
enough room for two people
and as members
um we'll remember at that point we did
have the area to
my right members left where we had
recording equipment so that prevented us
being able to use that area as members
will be aware that that has now been
removed
now the view of offices is that the
current approach that we have taken is
in accordance with the council's
resolution at that point and the risk
assessments were were taken at that
point having regard to the relevant
legislation which is the regulatory
reform fire safety order 2005. the
management of health and safety at work
regulations 1999 and the building Act
2010.
at that point
um the reception area
um as well as the naughty room were used
as an overflow area to accommodate the
viewing of proceedings
using the reception area in particular
ensures the quality of access and ease
of access to master points
the regulatory reform fire safety order
2005 does place a number of broad
responsibilities on the council to
ensure so far as it's reasonably
practical the safety of its employees
with regards to fire the general duty
also extends to non-employees to ensure
that it takes appropriate fire
precautions to keep its premises safe
and various guidance documents exist and
the authority must have regard to those
when setting out its measures
one particular aspect regarding fire
safety concerns the occupancy of
buildings and the British standard
bs9999 of 2017 which is a far safety in
design management and use of building
code of practice
and the building control approved
document B
and the local government the communities
and local government fire safety
guidance
fire safety in small and medium places
of assembly all provide recommendations
on the number of occupants in relation
to the space and the layout within
buildings
the guidance is clear that when
occupants are seated in this type of
venue such as a meeting or committee
room a minimum of one meter squared is
required for each person
to calculate this only available space
can be included fix parts of the
building structure must be excluded
as I said at the start when we when
Council last considered this matter at
that point in time the area used by the
public had that six meter square area
the approach that has been taken to date
recognizes that there are two distinct
areas of the council chamber the area
for the public to view proceedings and
the area for members and officers to
conduct the business of the council
it's also considered appropriate to keep
the two areas separate in order to
segregate those who are unfamiliar with
the building I.E the public and those
who would also would ordinarily be
familiar with the layout of a building
such as members and offices and that's
for the purposes of Fire Marshals
managing a fire evacuation they'd be
able to identify members that would be
used to fire EV actuation process and
members the public that may be
unfamiliar with the layout
the public area was previously assessed
a six meter squared but with the former
streaming area now unoccupied the same
calculation of occupancy can be applied
to the seating to seated men to seek
members of the public in that area
using the approach we have previously
used of that designated area being one
person to one square meter means that we
can have now a further five seats which
is the areas that we are now using so in
total the current public viewing area
can accommodate six members of the
public or 11 members of the public
the total floor area of the council
chamber has been assessed as
approximately 78 square meters and that
includes both areas
um
when we have applied the calculation to
the public area it's only right that we
use the same principles to reach a view
about what is an acceptable level of
occupancy for the rest of the council
chamber which is Youth for members and
officers to conduct business
using the same approach would result in
using the same approach for the whole
Council chamber of one person to one
square meter would mean that the whole
room would be able to accommodate 78.
less the 11 in the public area which
would mean the potential for the member
area and officer area to accommodate six
to seven sorry how many was that 67 67.
so that's the total floor area which
would equate to 78 occupants minus the
11 that's been allocated for the public
area which means the officer a member
area has the potential for 67.
occupants
um
we've done we don't need
um does this include the furniture I
mean the furniture takes up space uh Mrs
Green
at Sherman that the 78 is a total
um that's that's the starting point for
any calculation chairman so 78 would be
for the total chamber the maximum that
would be recommended however as I'll
explain there are reasons why that isn't
an appropriate level
I'm sorry that's that's that's fine
chairman so on reaching a view on a safe
level of occupancy we have to consider
the number of fire exits and the
restricted width between the exit point
which one of which is a top table here
and there is a restricted width um it is
quite a narrow area it is not the
um not the area that would you would
normally expect for a for a fire exit
and therefore there's also so that's
that's the first point
um so there's also the fixed furniture
and the restrictions of the overall
layout
so whilst
theoretically up to 67 people could
occupy that the the membrane officer
area
The View reached is at the occupancy
level in total for the member and
officer area should be restricted to 44.
so that means in total the council
chamber whilst potentially could have 67
occupants
we're recommending that the maximum
occupancy should be 55 which is 44 in
the member and officer area and 11 for
the members of the public
and that would be a number that will be
acceptable should only one exit be
available
we've also looked at the calculated
travel distance between the Escape
stairwells and that seemed to be
acceptable as well
it is possible that following the change
of the floor level at the back of the
chamber that we could potentially extend
the public seating area
because they previously work would have
been physical barriers so that is
possible to extend the public seating
area that that would mean that the
members of the public would then be
encroaching on what historically would
have been the area that members would
have used so it is possible to look at
extending the area from where it is now
and essentially where those two chairs
are
we could potentially look at extending
the public area into that area but that
would be something we'd have to to go
back and have a look at but when these
assessments were done it was based upon
the original area that was designated
for the public
foreign
so the at the moment the risk assessment
does keep the public area
to the same to into the same area that
it was previously
uh yeah I I don't want to
um
interfere but I think members have got
the full understanding of the council
chamber
um the other issue is the norvi room
would you like to address that that's it
the the use of the northie room
um is historically we have used either
the reception area or the naughty room
but officers feel that the use of the
reception area is a more acceptable
overflow for the public and that's for a
number of reasons that's due to the ease
of access to enable us to meet the
equality act so if we had somebody with
any mobility issues it would be much
easier for them to be able to access the
ground floor
um it's much easier to access the master
points if there was a fire that anybody
in the northern room there would be much
further to go and again if somebody had
any Mobility or disablement that meant
that they couldn't use the stairs that
again would be more difficult to be able
to manage
um
and there's also the um the
ease of X exit from the building
um again the reception area has a very
easy access out of the building
and the maximum occupancy levels taken
into account the number of exits and the
seating arrangements
um would have to take account of the
fact that
um we would if there were more than 50
seats there would have to be specific
seating arrangements put in place but
the the reception area does have a much
larger area and it is easier to access
so in conclusion it's a view of the
council's health and safety officer that
the number of occupants should be
determined in accordance with the
approach that we have set out which has
been informed by legislation and
guidance
and we feel that the currently that the
public area should have a maximum
occupancy of 11 which
could potentially be reviewed if members
reminded to extend the public viewing
area and that the member and officer
area should be restricted to 44.
it's also our view that the reception
area would be the most appropriate safe
and accessible area to accommodate an
overflow for the public to view
proceedings where the maximum occupancy
levels of the public area of the council
chamber have been met
thank you chairman thank you Mrs Green
um uh members now what we'll do we'll
have members debate then we'll come to
the leader as a penultimate speaker and
then uh councilor Lagann uh will
um
sum up
members
councilor Swain yes thank you chairman
some interesting points there um
particularly regarding um uh fire exit
difficulties
um and particularly relating to the
northern one
um and as far as reception area is
concerned
that I know there's a large area in
principle there it um
it would take a lot of reorganizing to
actually prepare for the possibility of
so many members of the public to be
wanting to attend uh unless that can be
sort of worked out for some part of it
um but it means that two or three
aspects of this motion as it stands are
impractical the one about
all restrictions on public access the
reference the uh and reference the
northern one
um so
um we've got a situation where it's
maybe possible as far as I see it that
the
um only real realistic um scope for an
overflow is to use the reception area in
some way or part of it
um but this would have implications for
logistically
um in advance of any meeting thank you
thank you um uh we have used the
reception room at the reception area uh
before and it has worked quite well
councilor stamp thank you chairman can I
just have Clarity from Miss green she
said at one stage one fire exit well
we've got two fire exits and I just want
to check my numbers because I wrote down
what you were saying and and chairman if
we actually looked at maybe chopping
when the screen stops you'd have better
access to uh to go to that door because
in your presentation she said difficulty
getting to that access so that could
surely be an option and I think we've
all been here when we've had really
contentious planning applications and if
I'm allowed to say the AAA dog rescue
was one of them where there was numerous
people downstairs upstairs and
everywhere and that was actually quite
quite stressful
um I'm going to disagree a little bit
with my fellow councilor Council Lagan
here because I do think we should be
able to have access to the northern room
because I think that from the what
residents have come back to me with the
less planning meeting it's one I was
away at and couldn't couldn't attend and
wasn't allowed to speak they felt
disenfranchised from the council meeting
and they felt as though the council
wasn't allowing them to come into the
chamber to listen to the actual debate
so I think you've got an area that
you're going to have to try and if this
motion is amended in any way which I'm
sure it will be that the residents don't
feel as though you or this council is
stopping engagement from them and
participation with the council but other
than that if I could have an answer to
that I think we should go back to what
we had before there used to be two rows
of chairs and I know them well because
we used to sit here because God knows
family is before I was elected and I
don't see why we can't go back to that
it was it was safe safe then why is it
not safe now thank you Jim
um this this Council chamber was
designed almost 50 years ago and
different health and safety regulations
in fact it probably wasn't any health
and safety regulations then uh and it is
starting to show that this Council
chamber is perhaps not fit for purpose
um well I I mean we had for example
Council appeal in a wheelchair last
night
and it was very difficult for him to
access this Council chamber if a future
chairman is wheelchair-bound there's no
way that they can get up here
safely
so these are considerations but I mean
I'm getting off the point
yeah um
councilor stilts
oh
yeah
Mrs Green
um thank you chairman
um it would be an option to be able to
make the access to the exit easier
it wouldn't change some of the other
concerns which are around the fixed
furniture
because it would there would be still be
issues in terms of being able to for
people to be able to move around it it's
the fixed no fixed nature of the
furniture I don't know if Mr baccarini
would like to add anything uh yes thanks
I think so um this is a concern the
width of the exit here so the
calculations we've done so far would
allow if we had only one exit the the
capacity or the occupancy we've
suggested that would still be sufficient
yes you could modify the room I don't
doubt that I've not considered that but
if that's something that you want us to
consider we can
um we could chop this top table yes but
there are restricted whips say here
where members are sitting and the fixed
Furniture doesn't help that so we may
have to then look at other
configurations of the room to go to
their occupancy and
this exit here cannot be classified in
my view as a fire exit
uh it may say that but how does one get
a pass to open the door
regular switch
uh well I'm just saying that at the
moment it cannot be accepted in my view
as a fire exit because you need a pass
to get through it and the fire exit
should
be awesome
oh I'm told it'll automatically open but
I don't I don't know that uh councilor
stilts sorry thank you Mr chair I
actually agree with uh councilor stamp I
think that this room you've got so much
desk space and and you know if that is
an option of using that door as a fire
exit and those doors should
automatically open if there is a fire
anyway I think that this room layout
perhaps needs to be re-looked at and I
think we should be looking at how this
could be reconfigured I know it would
cost this Council Nano but it's
something that if we want to be letting
members of the public in if we want to
have disabled people counselors and
public come in we should be looking at
the other thing is we have a lift for
our disabled people where is it how do
they get to it and then with the nausea
room there is actually two exits but one
of them is downstairs
so if there were people in the norvey
room and we did open the northern room
up to public when we had the screen and
the chairs in there
um we had that problem then so if there
had been a fire how were we going to get
those people up but we still opened it
up to the public so I think I agree with
uh councilor stamp that we should be
looking at this
any other member
Council Fluker yes thank you chairman
um
can I apologize for my dress today Jim
and I think it's the I think it's the
only time I've come to a council meeting
or any meeting without wearing tie uh
and and it's because I've got to go to
work shortly which I feel might
interfere business
um a couple of questions this thing
about fixed Furniture
um you know I'm fairly up to speed with
building regulations through my work and
and we're working on the project at the
moment where the 12 000 customers told
us the furniture has to be fixed to
prevent it falling over so if there's a
stampede from premises then it can
obviously interfere with access
um my sort of overarching concern about
all of this is is surely these premises
have been inspected by a six Farm Rescue
Services
they are open to the public and they
should be inspected so my first question
is
um can you please give us an update from
the last fire inspection so that we
members can understand
what points they've highlighted of
concern and whether or not we should
really be operating in here
um you know my my feeling is we've we
went through a process we went you know
I can see there's two sides here there's
a health and safety one and there's an
access issue and I think the council
stalks is quite right in what she says
you know this is certainly not what I
would call DDA compliant access is not
DDA compliant which means we are not DDA
compliant and and I know that we've
looked at various things you know I can
remember some Grand projects and good
glassing over the top of the courtyard
and using that as a breakout space and
and doing all of that clearly that's not
going to happen
um you know even though we don't really
have a timeline for what's happening
with the princess Road campus but you
know maybe this is the time instead of
trying to stick yet another sticking
plaster over this room and the
relationship between this room and the
northern maybe we should be looking now
towards having a breakout area within
the council and a classic example of
that is I think of top made I think it's
where Braintree have a multi-functioning
room put me right if I'm wrong
um but you know there's absolutely no no
reason why we couldn't actually use the
area downstairs in reception with a
little bit of changing it could work so
we just have portable tables portable
chairs uh and we just all pitch up down
there it'd be quite simple to do it
um but I I agree with counselors stamp I
mean I do know that members of the
public feel totally disenfranchised at
this Council and perhaps none other
because they can't come into the chamber
this is not something that's new this
has been going on a long long time but
what generally disappoints me about this
is the fact that you know had this
matter been referred to uh a committee
they would have had the benefit of
reading Miss Green's report in advance
which would have been very very helpful
and that would have helped them chairman
form a decision and move the thing
forward because I think really and truly
the thing that's come out of this is is
that we are not health and safety you
can plan and we're certainly not DDA
compliant so that means every time you
have a meeting here offices and members
are at risk thank you
um
uh Mrs Green do you wish to comment
before I think that's the last speaker
oh sorry yeah uh Mrs Green
is there anything there you need to
respond to
um I think probably just um one thing
chairman is where we we were talking
about making changes to the council
chamber area in terms of making the
changes perhaps to make this area a
bit easier to access that's only going
to change the occupancy levels for the
member area and as members have said um
this morning
um that isn't actually going to increase
the area that's available for the public
to see it it would just make it easier
for
um to potentially have increased number
of occupants for the member and officer
area making these changes here wouldn't
make any difference to the total numbers
of
spaces that would be available to the
public unless there as members have
suggested
changing the layout of the room
completely
um oh sorry sorry chairman just one
final thing just to Echo your comments
that yes we have very successfully used
the reception area
um we have already got TVs installed
down there so it's very easy for for us
to be able to accommodate that
um and that wouldn't be a problem we'd
never previously had any issues in terms
of accommodating an overflowing
reception area
um Mr Holmes wishes to say something
thank you Jim I think it would be
helpful if officers provided a written
statement then regarding the health and
safety of this building and also the
means of access and my belief is that we
have uh carried out reasonable
adjustments for Access you'll see their
levels change um in the in the seating
area below to allow a disability person
with impediment to actually access the
building we do have a lift but also we
need to give you that reassurance around
uh fire safety so I think the best thing
to do is that we issue that to members
in writing and I'll get Mr Pickering to
uh to do that
um the account the um the floor level
changes in this uh chamber mean that I
can't see people sitting on in some
places on the other
uh uh rank um Mrs uh councilor Thompson
sorry thank you chairman um just to add
a further complication much depends on
where this
potential fire is because it's right
outside that door something if the
leader's office went up in smoke that
would create enormous difficulties for
anybody in there
um but that instantly brings
difficulties with getting anyone out of
the naughty room in a hurry yeah so you
know these things are never as
straightforward as they sound okay
Council Fleming
thank you Chad I just wanted to ask my
screen how many members of the public
did we accommodate pre-covered pre these
um arrangements and then also with the
going back to the fire risk assessment I
just wanted to be assured that that's
done every year and that the fire
service have attended I sort of had
assumed that that was standard thank you
Mrs Green
um
I can't answer that here and now I'd
have to go back and check the previous
assessments that were done as to the
numbers
um that were previously accommodated
um
I would Hazard I guess probably not many
more than the currently here but we can
certainly come back to members on that
and regarding the fire safety
um there is a regular inspection from a
health and safety perspective but in
terms of the
um Fire Authority I don't know if Mr
baccarini can answer that yes with
regards to the Fire Authority an
approach has been made and they've been
invited to attend and look at our fire
precautions one of the issues that will
be raised will be this room at the
moment we're waiting a response from
them we're trying to get to visits a
familiarization visit from the local
station so the crews are aware of the
layout of the building and then also uh
fire safety officer who can help advise
on our precautions
you have spoken before
that's just an amendment oh yeah I'll
take that in a second then
thank you chair
um thank Kim it's good I'm a little bit
surprised with that because we've we've
just had the fire service just turn up
and say hand over your fire safety your
risk assessment documents there and then
um you know usually they ring they give
a couple of days notice if you're not
around they can be quite insistent so I
am a little surprised that they've not
been before to be honest with you
uh councilor white
um thank you Mr chairman
um I I'd just like to say that um I
think we could probably simplify this by
just going back to the pre-covered rules
in line with health and safety and the
fire service
um because we're used to Incarnate a lot
of people before so my amendment is that
we um go back to the pre-covid public
protocols and if there are overflows we
um house them in the reception
um pending any further updates in line
with health and safety and fire and
safety regulations that's an amendment
is that seconded that's second end
um
this this this opens uh the opportunity
to cancel fluka to respond to that
Amendment
um I wonder if the officer can confirm
to council what prompted him to call
Essex fire service to carry out an
inspection and I think
um from what I think my screen just said
it's some years since this these
premises have been inspected which
concerns me enormously because several
premises that I'm involved in we seem to
have I mean well an inspection every I
think I can see councilor Fleming not
nodding almost every year and this
building is open to the public so I'm
enormously concerned that I haven't done
one in the last 12 months but perhaps Mr
Holmes when you release that document to
members you could include a copy of the
last fire inspection please no not the
next one I think that wasn't necessarily
responding to the amendment but I think
Mr Holmes wishes to say something
yes members I'll clarify the position my
understanding is the fire service
stopped regular inspections and I've
been the facilities manager before and I
remember those visits unannounced two
days notice um but my understanding is
they cease doing that for this building
um I don't know the background to that
but I will certainly double check uh in
terms of the understanding
um but you know if that is the case
obviously the council completely would
cooperate with the fire service to do
that but my understanding is that wasn't
a routine anymore for this building but
I will check that and as I do the other
update I'll include that detail
councilor Spencer can I sorry can I just
be clear have we had a wheelchair access
[Music]
um
done for this chamber
um because I can't yes the uh uh Mr
Holmes says yes oh okay chairman there
have been um adaptations to this room um
it probably in the last two years under
the split level flooring I mean there's
two issues really in terms of providing
access for the public to get into the
the council chamber and there is a lift
it's accessed through the reception it
comes through the uh private offices
it's not it's not convenient but that's
what happens and you are able to access
the chamber you see the doors have got
push buttons on to get you as far as the
chamber the more difficult challenge
would be if there was a member with a
disability
um because that would seriously impact
on how we could use this room in terms
of access
um so I think there's two parts to it
really
thank you chair yes with regard to um
councilor beer last night his wheelchair
had to be lifted up the stairs no there
is no um there is no sloping floor here
his wheelchair had to be lifted I just
liked it I I did make that point I think
earlier on
um
do you want to say something Mr Holmes I
completely agree members and I think the
only way to do this is to do a complete
review of this room the layout is is
very fixed there's a lot of space here
but it is tied up with very fixed desks
um so if we looked at a redesign of this
room we might be able to improve that
accommodation and also there's been
other suggestions of the location on the
ground floor which obviously would
remove that altogether so if members are
asking us to do a review of the council
chamber facilities we could do that but
it would have to be a fairly detailed
review to make sure we can include all
the necessary requirements councilor
Morgan
thank you Mr chairman it's really more
of a question I'm obviously still quite
new to all this
does is the domestic arrangements for
the council chamber and the council
offices does that not come under one of
the members committees and if it doesn't
shouldn't a committee be formed to
actually Overlook
it's in the purview of SNL right
but in that case shouldn't SNR therefore
look at this in some detail the producer
report for members
well we're already looking at uh an
amendment
uh Council uh councilor uh Stevens
thank you chair just
just to the wording of this motion and
we were talking about amendments this is
perhaps slightly pedantic but to avoid
us getting caught out with it later
um it reads that the council removes all
restrictions on public access to
meetings in the chamber and if there are
more members of the public attend and
cannot be accommodated I think that
should say and if there are more members
of the public attending than can be
accommodated in the chamber and I think
that the numbers really need to be set
out in here because otherwise it means
it's totally meaningless I could get a
hundred people in here obviously I'd be
breaking the law I know it goes on to
talk about the requirements of the
equality act and access requirements but
I don't think
it talks about health and safety
requirements I think we need to State
the numbers in here and it says and it
should say then can be accommodated
thank you thank you we uh councilman uh
Logan
um can I ask you a question are you
adverse to the proposed amendment as
long as I can see what the proposed
amendment but I also want to I've also
also
um
um I want to raise a few comments as
well yeah well you will have that
opportunity but I just thought I don't
have the amendment
um is that possible Miss bird
I think it was simply to to go back to
pre-coved
level I never know when we reach that
number which is required in the change
yeah
if I might help
um my amendment was to propose that we
go back to the pre-covered protocols for
members of the public so they can attend
and if there is no overflow that we
accommodate them in the reception area
and I think I'd like to add on pending a
review of the council facilities um bias
now but I suspect this will take several
months because obviously it's going to
be quite a lengthy report but I think in
the interim my Amendment um is what I
remember posing I think
I think councilor uh Langan that um that
do you disagree with that amendment I
think that more or less meets all your
requirements
my requirement was to look at numbers
but yeah um I wouldn't be adverse to
that yeah uh leader would you like the
penultimate um say on this before I come
back to councilor Logan although no
we've got to take Miss White's Amendment
first sorry
God Clarity chairman is it going back to
us is it going to SNR then no uh
the amend the amendment needs to be
voted on
um but I'm asking uh the leader if she
wishes to respond to the motion and the
amendment
okay
leader
leader do you wish to say anything
um well chairman happy to obviously I
think it's clear we've got certain
regulations here it's his Council must
be seen to abide by
um councilor whites put on the table we
go back to pre-covered processes and
should then obviously the numbers be in
excess of what is permitted in the
chamber that those residents
um are are directed towards the
reception area I have to say I think the
reception area is a much better area for
the Overflow than the northern room if
I'm Frank and I do remember a fairly
recent meeting where it did cause
tremendous problems within the northern
whereas that would have been so much
exacerbated if it was
um the reception area and which is a
much more open area than being herded
into the training room and for the
reasons we've all heard today rather
than tonight I was going to say
councilor White's put on that
councilor whites put on that Amendment
and that seems quite reasonable I mean I
do recall I'm sure Mr Holmes will recall
um that this chamber has been looked at
before and in terms I remember quite um
recently on well perhaps my memory is
wrong where there was a move to talk
about going downstairs with the council
chamber I forget why what why that
didn't happen or appear but and of
course Mr Holmes has indicated he's
happy to do these reports and updates
for all members which I think is also a
good move also of course and I can't go
into all the details and I don't want to
start a debate off of this but we're
looking at certain areas aspects
regarding our offices on Princes Road
anyway so whether or not something comes
into the equation regarding the fixed
Furniture here I mean I have seen
authorities but we've got to think
there's costs apply to this whereby they
do have movable
desks and chairs and then that that
space can also be then used for a
multitude of other things I'm not
honestly advocating that but that might
be what councilor white is sort of
indicating like asking for her her
committee and chairman as a chairman
anyway she could ask for that
um to be done so chairman we do have to
abide by the health and safety
um rules and I'm not going to Advocate
anything different to that on behalf of
this Council because that would be very
very responsible and I also think is
very very important though that we need
to be a man for that our residents need
to be aware of this so we need to have
this clearly
um advertised on our websites wherever
and I think actually we ought to have
suitable notices
um in specific areas in in this
Council entrance or wherever or coming
up the stairs so the members of the
public are clear and that they don't
arrive and then come and not have the
expectation that they could find
themselves not being able to sit in the
chamber thank you chairman um I think
um we we have a minor problem with
actually using the words recovered level
um uh and I think Mr Holmes will explain
I think the essential issue members
who've done a risk assessment we've done
our calculations that's the number it's
given us my suggestion is we do adopt
that we have 11 spaces for the public
we've said we've got your members in
your existing we need to do some more
work then in terms of what our options
might be but that would keep us legal it
will keep us safe in terms of occupancy
levels if indeed that can change uh
after those reviews that will be the
safest way forward I would suggest so
that would be my advice to you we work
with the risk assessment we have the
occupancy levels that we've outlined to
you today and then we do some extra work
to say could we make any changes to that
um
counseling that's what I meant actually
but um you know the numbers might arrive
but then not to go beyond what we're
allowed to as a council so people would
be right redirected down to reception
that's how I interpret it so it's not
pre-covered it's 11 in the council
chamber and the the rest redirected to
the reception area is that is that thank
you yeah thank you Mr chairman yes I
think what I'm trying to say is that we
stick to the health and safety levels
and allow the maximum amount of public
we can safely admit into the chamber and
any overflow gets accommodated into the
reception area okay yeah so uh your
second agrees that yeah
um councilor Lagan
um
yeah you I think it's for you to sum up
now and if are you going to accept that
Amendment well um the the spirit the
motion it is with what the amendment is
within the spirit of the motion the only
thing that really changes is the naughty
room
to be honest yeah the way I look at it
there's a there's a few points first of
all just to council Stevens benefit
um the the last statement about health
and safety requirements doesn't mean
exactly what the officers have presented
to us because the motion has to fit in
with what current legislation actually
says in the fire safety order 2005 is
very clear in public buildings I commend
the officers Miss green and Mr I can't
even quite catch your name
welcome okay so um Good Luck
um and you've got a lot of work to do
um it's from from One Professional to
another so I'm looking forward to it
hopefully working alongside you and with
you
um
what the officers have presented is
exactly what we needed to do we can't
just fill the chamber up with hundreds
of people it's just not it's not allowed
this is a very old chamber yeah we're
not getting slaves of people rocking up
are we the council meetings but I think
a lot of that to be fair is because
we've restricted people and it's very
difficult I had a resident right to me
so it's easy to get into the House of
Commons than it is to get into
here okay so to view democracy so we are
taking the steps forward there's a
simple solution Mr Holmes has actually
said that look at a paper just rip all
the fixed fittings out you know we've
got 750 mil we need to have those
doorways but that's a restricted area
which we've been have we been acting
unlawfully no
okay we definitely definitely haven't
will we meet fire requirements yes
but there's always things that can be
done better and this debate has actually
highlighted that so I agree with the
motion but I think what a couple of
members have said about just knocking
this whole thing down making fold up
over the tables I'm not pretty about
sitting on this Green Bays I just want
to be able to sit here have the debates
and have more people if we can get
closer in if they wish to come in and
they can access an egress the building
safely so I'm more than happy and I
thank the officers for what they did
because it's very very clear working in
that field to get that amount of detail
is it's really important that members
understand that hey we want loads of
people in here
but the legislation doesn't allow us but
we can get in as many as we can so I'm
happy with the amendment order motion
just to get more people in thank you um
therefore
um I'll put the amendment
um uh to the vote and are we quite clear
on what the amendment is yeah
yeah
okay
can it be on the screen Miss bird
yes
they have the safety levels and allow
the maximum amount of public in the
chamber and any of the facing the
reception area yeah that's it simplified
also there was but I would suggest that
as chairman of essence okay you do that
as chairman of SNL she can do that
herself
uh because that that would change the
whole motion
um right do members agree the uh
Amendment you agreed thank you I
therefore put the substantive motion uh
uh which is uh in effect the amendment
you agreed agreed thank you right
well let's take a nearly an hour so we
could have a 15-hour session in front of
us
motion one okay
counselor Lagan
um chairman I don't I have a motion
that's been second I'd actually like to
make a slight Amendment if that's
acceptable
um
it's only adding a couple of words with
your second who was your secondary
Council stamp yeah would you agree a
start amendment can I listen to it first
fair enough
um so you'll you'll need to move uh what
do you want to change I think I think Mr
quelch
um a motion mover can do that no it's
just those words
highlight the amended wording I want to
use yeah yeah okay so it's is that
members review the provision of land
Supply data and change to words added
build out rates as advised by the
developer those words are added on a
quarterly basis and that the annual land
Supply statement is reviewed and agreed
by Council prior to its publication so
the additionals are changed to and as
advised by the developer
um uh
um Mr Mr Holmes um is is that uh a
problem with an officer response
chairman I'd like to invite Mr Winslow
to join the top table to respond yeah
thank you Mr Winslow
what happens
um yeah yeah so is Mr Winslow that says
that that will be acceptable
yes chairman yeah okay uh Mr Winslow
uh thank you chairman that's that's fine
I can still answer to that
carry on okay
sorry okay chairman um currently a
quarterly position statement on the
five-year housing now supplier is
reported to PGA committee on the
corporate risk register risk seven that
deals with the monitoring of the
five-year housing land supplier since
the risk was created in 2018. whilst
it's possible to report on the majority
of the five-year housing land Supply
data quarterly due to the current
development monitoring approach used
this would need to be caveated that it
would not be equivalent to the data
presented in the annual statement the
reason for this is residential
completion monitoring which includes
site visits to development sites eye
officers to validate unit completions
can occurs annually every April to May
after the end of what is called the plan
monitoring period which is set out in
the local development plan that finishes
on the 31st of March every year this
scheduling ensures consistency with
other Essex authorities and informs the
National Data returns to government
to present a complete picture on a
quarterly basis
would require the validation of
completions of our site visits on a
quarterly basis rather than annually as
a comparison the freak this frequency of
visits is not justified to meet the
tasks of updating the planning inspector
as to the five-year housing land Supply
positions at related planning pills were
we to introduce quarterly site visits
this will impact on other areas of work
as it will be additional activities over
and above existing commitments chairman
the suggestion that the council approves
The Five-Year housing land Supply report
itself is not an issue and that can be
introduced should Council wish although
it will not give any more weight in the
planning process as it's only a snapshot
in time report members should also bear
in mind that unless other Provisions
were made it may delay its publication
from being as close to April as possible
due to the program of the council
through the municipal year this year for
instance it would be presented for
approval on the current schedule on the
13th of July the First Council after
statutory annual Council
finally chairman the motion does deal
with matters which could be picked up by
The Five-Year housing land Supply
working group and the additional wording
that councilor Lagan refers to have been
discussed at the five year housing land
Supply working group that remains
underway and is currently decided that
it's going to present or going to seek
advice from a barrister that work hasn't
that work hasn't completed yet
um but it could look it could consider
and consider reporting frequency as part
of its holistic work on that matter
fine
um thank you
um
uh right members councilor Morgan
oh yeah yeah secretary I'm frankly
puzzled as to why we're having this
debate because as the officer has
pointed out there is a five-year housing
land Supply working group who's
responsible for looking into this and
coming back to reporting to council so
I'm quite surprised why why we're
needing to sort of Institute other sort
of procedures since that is already in
place thank you thank you councilors Dan
thank you um forgive me and correct me
if I'm wrong I thought the five-year
land Supply working group was a
fact-founding short-lived group and it
was only actually
um was supposed to finish in November or
December last year to give the
information to this Council I wasn't
aware that that was a continuous group
that was approved at the statutory
annual so can you answer me that the
second point I'd like to raise is that
um I thought this Council had passed a
resolution that the officers were going
to visit the site the Strategic sites on
a regular basis to agree completions so
we could charge the the um cancer tax
sooner because it was raised that we
weren't collecting the revenue in
quickly enough on completions now I
could I could be dreaming it chairman
but I don't think I am and so I would
have thought that would easily sit
alongside this motion chairman thank you
I um I think
um that I remember that but I don't know
that I remember it as a motion but Mr
Winslow have you got an answer to that
um in terms of the five year housing
land Supply working group it's got
specific terms of reference which
include uh reporting back to council it
has no time limit on it it doesn't say
in the terms of reference it has to do
it by a certain time and the working
group is going through the the process
which it is in terms of the uh councilor
stamps final part uh chairman so the
completion of properties for council tax
and for planning purposes is different
um but we do try to use council tax
records and other things as indicators
but the final uh
consistently carried out across all
Essex authorities is via a site visit
Tim we're gonna come back
it's in the same data we're supposed to
be smarter working if you can actually
use that information for another
planning policy from planning whichever
Japan it comes in I think that would be
beneficial and the other point is
Chairman
sorry I know you're speaking oh wait is
can you confirm that that working group
was supposed to be it was in the minutes
you said yourself you was hoping that
information was coming back by December
or November that year and we've checked
those minutes and it says quite clearly
I wasn't aware that this Council had
agreed that that working group was
partly agreed to go on for as long as it
what it was It was supposed to be
fact-finding chairman I I uh if the
chairman makes a comment that's not
necessarily uh agreed by Council and I
did say I I I agree I did say I hope it
would be able to report hope it would be
able to report by December
um we're gonna come back all you're
doing is letting this Council prolong
what should be information that is
required at the time chairman it's not
acceptable can I ask Mrs Green about
completions
uh is that within your brief Mrs Green
myself and Mr Winslow we can confirm
that the definitions are different so
substantially complete for the purposes
of council tax legislation is is
slightly different so you complete for
the purposes of planning purposes yeah
but but I think Mrs stamps
um question was do do we visit these
sites and check the completions yeah
so
um if I'm a chairman so we visit them
for planning purposes
um so to validate uh whether uh they are
occupiable
um uh so we do that for planning
purposes for council tax purposes I I
can't comment as I'm not the relevant
that's why I uh I'm perhaps unfairly
asked Mrs Green if she was aware but she
isn't uh councilor Swain
um
Andrew of what's been said about regular
reporting uh to PG a where
the scope for the caveats that Mr
Winslow has mentioned it's only really
with regard to the annual statement that
we needed to want it to come for
um approval by Council before
publication so the motion is
unexceptional I'm I don't know whether
the wording that um
um additional wording that councilman
Wagner suggests it actually helped his
cause because
um how the um the numbers are calculated
and whether it's on developer proposals
or not is all part of any discussion of
the quarterly updates being presented to
PG a it'll become clear there as part of
the explanation so in a sense what is
the the additional wording He suggests
putting it seems to be a bit more
restrictive on his own Amendment
um so I just I would Advocate that the
amendment as it the emotion as it stands
councilor Spencer
okay so what I'm going to say now is
that however we do it we need to have a
way of scrutinizing the five-year land
Supply going forward because I was
elected in April I don't know you know
I'm not I've not been a member of pdna
but what I do know is that the scrutiny
hadn't been sufficient and I'm going to
say that now because that land Supply
did not contain all the figures that it
should have done and that should that
need we need to find a mechanism without
going to lots of extra trouble and
making it unsustainable for officers but
we need do need to have a mechanism
where this Council has an opportunity to
scrutinize that because clearly what's
already in place didn't work and we now
have some confusion over the working
group and what its role actually is I
fear so we just need we need to look at
it from that point of view and find a
way forward thank you
um the penultimates of I was going to
say the penultimate is going to give a
council of Fluker who's hidden behind
Mrs Fleming I'm sure you've always got
your eye on me chairman
um I'm sorry I'll keep waiting Mrs
Fleming because I think she might have
been with me too actually
did you raise your hand or were you
flicking your hair oh I'm sorry okay
um
land Supply as far as I can remember and
I think I'm a member of the of the
working group I certainly attend I think
it was actually set up to look at the
mechanics of of how we were dealing with
the five-year housing Landslide and in
in many many ways that member engagement
has been hugely successful because we
know that we are moving towards having a
five-year housing land Supply and and I
hear the arguments about checking if
houses are finished or checking if
houses have started but the whole idea
of the five-year housing lands plan is
one falls off one end unless you put one
in the bottom you no longer have a
five-year housing land Supply so you
know the tenacity in which we do this
can affect our overall performance in
relation to the five of your housing
Landslide but I agree what council
dispensely says because one of the most
bizarre things I heard in the working
group for some time is when an officer
asks the members in the working group
who were going to appear Gap if they can
ask the applicant what the build out
rate was on another site because they
hadn't been able to make contact with
the people on that site so you know
whilst I I accept what Mr Winslow says
um I think members need to be put back
into their comfort zone with regards to
to site visits and the way that we
communicate with the developers because
I think we are still missing some
figures and I think the fact that if the
members were asked to ask a developer
about build out rates and clearly we're
not engaging I won't mention the
company's name because it wouldn't be
fair thank you counselor councilor White
I was just going to amend this that
motion one gets sent to the pg uh an AE
committee and um they can have the data
rates rather than wasting time with this
at Full Count so I think that's where it
should go
thank you Chad
um Matt you're right it does we do get
um the figures in the risk register but
it's a bit of a sort of broad brush
here's the I think the working the
conversations you have at working group
and committee they're they're completely
different
um so I I mean for me all scrutiny is
good everybody benefits from scrutiny so
whether the working group is permanent
or not I think it should be permanent
and the figures should be looked at
quarterly I I really think that
everybody would benefit from that
conversation
thank you Mr chairman as the chair of
that working group
um I will say that one of the
discussions we've had is that the one of
the officers does foam those
Builders to find at their building rate
but they won't always answer to it I
thought what I would like to ask Mr
Winslow is we are waiting for that
questions that we put to that Barrister
can we answer can we do this before we
have those answers back from him Mr
Winslow would you answer that then I'll
come to the leader thank you chairman
um well I suppose you could technically
but you could get advice back which is
different and then you may look to
change your decision so obso you haven't
got the benefit of the council advice
yet so that was what the working group
had asked to do
thank you uh leader
thank you thank you chairman
um well we've heard from Mr Winslow how
of course there is reporting to PGA
um on a corporate risk register that
goes regularly regarding the five year
housing land Supply and also made the
point I think that obviously further
reporting if you're looking at saying
it's increased and you've equally got to
realize the way that can go and that
you've got to do regular reporting when
the numbers go down regarding the five
year housing land Supply working group
council Mrs Flemings
Rays the point of uh should perhaps be
permanent now actually in a way this
motion could be seen to prejudge
possibly some outcomes of that working
group and councilor Stills referred to
what we've asked and we're waiting for
and I think we do need to have that come
back to the working group and indeed
because we don't know yet what the
findings are or recommendations that may
or not come out of that and I think
that's a very good body to be looking at
things going forward and it's not time
limited to my knowledge unless I'm wrong
but I think actually that's been
ascertained tonight and I I think that
five-year housing Enterprise had some
very good discussions councilor
Fleming's absolutely correct in a
working group you do have different
discussions there's more fluidity in
people being able to speak take up um
sort of thinking from others as well in
a committee it's more structured and
everything so my recommendation would be
we need to rate until we have the
findings that come back to the five-year
housing land Supply and I think that's a
vehicle that can a deal actually with
these issues and PGA as well that would
be what I would indicate chairman
because I do think we need to have those
findings we need to know what the
recommendations are and um that could
have some then lead to a discussion on
how frequently any future reporting
should be and that working group reports
back to council I actually think there
should be a report coming back a
holistic report from that working group
from the chairman of that working group
to this Council they
can Mr Winslow confirm when the
five-year land Supply is going to be
published did he say July this year
thank you
no I didn't I didn't say I did mention
July in my uh statement to you
um uh if the terms of the motion were to
go through it may not be published until
July because that's the first Council
after statutory annual Council that
could hear the report and approve it
um we can publish it as soon as the
completion data is done and we would
Endeavor to do that within eight in
April
saying that we're going to stop it
well you'll delay it until July sorry
counselor would you like to sum up
please
very much so chair there's a few things
here one is the barrel The Five-Year
housing land Supply whole project was
born out of um
need to scrutinize information
which we found that there was errors in
spreadsheets Etc which should simply
since been corrected the land the five
year housing land Supply was put
together with 16 members of the council
with a great concern which is a huge
member a huge number of councilors that
showed their concern at that point the
working group was set to look at
methodology and what's in and what's out
that's been a good good group my
understanding of that that was a task
and Finnish group that had the terms of
reference may say so to answer councilor
Morgans on my view it was time limited
so it you know once we've done that work
that piece of work falls off and we we
stick with what we've got
um the Barrister has absolutely no
bearing the Barrister will look at the
process that's under being undertaken
and give us advice on that the motion is
is completely different for what what
that part of the conversation is
councilor Swain is not my cause it's the
district's cause
this is one of the most important things
we've had a huge massive errors come
forward with the way that we've we've
worked allowing certain developments to
happen because we haven't maintained a
five-year housing Supply so we need to
do everything we can and sometimes we
might not be able to do that so it is
what it is and it isn't what it isn't so
it's not my cause I'm standing here as a
district councilor trying to protect the
district and develop the district in a
way that can serve the future residents
when we're long gone
um wasting time counselor um
said I find that councilor white this is
this is not wasting time you know and I
don't normally buy it but that is I find
that quite disrespectful when it's
something as important as what we talk
about shaping the district and as a
councilor I have a high level of respect
for I was a bit disappointed in that so
really I I make no apology I stick with
the intent of the motion I believe that
the motion will give us what we want we
won't get as Mr Winslow's kindly said we
won't get everything accurate at that
point in time but it will give us a
snapshot and I think from a perspective
that we could delay until July or put an
extraordinary meeting in we can do that
technically I don't care when it is come
in we'll have the figures in now we can
get it done we have it scrutinized we'll
all agree or agree to disagree
um and then we publish that way we have
the whole process from start to finish
scrutinized we all get a chance to look
at it well the members who are in place
at the time will get a chance to look at
it and that way you can I'm not going to
use the word defend but you can justify
every decision that's made in every
calculation that's made
and I I would stand by this if it falls
it falls but I'd like to see it succeed
thank you thank you councilor login uh
we'll now put that to the vote can I
just have some clarification
um Mr Winslow Mr Winslow what you're
saying is if the motion succeeds there
will be a delay on the reporting of the
five-year housing then
that's completely wrong because I've
just addressed that in my closing
statement
uh
Miss low clearly said as far as
I heard it was that he couldn't publish
uh until June he couldn't publish until
July until the council in July had
agreed that's what he said councilor
Lagan has said an extraordinary meeting
could could deal with it okay
uh I I don't want to I don't want to
prolong the debate
um
uh we we will now move to the vote those
in favor
um
uh Mr Dodson want wants to give some
advice
oh once Mr quilts to give Mr quotes
uh and uh if you get me into trouble Mr
quilcher okay I'll find I'll talk to you
later okay
um
my colleague Mr Dodson just just made a
good point really and
um wanting to know about the
pre-election period the the because the
notice of poll will be given on the 13th
of March that means pre-election period
which was otherwise known as the perder
period but it's been renamed now
um will kick in from the 13th of March
and
the government advice is that you don't
put in contentious issues during that
period you can do normal business but
you should avoid as far as possible
dealing with issues that will be seen as
um having a lot of community interest
and potentially contentious because that
could have an influence on the election
that's the advice of government so in
other words do you ordinary business
your ordinary transactions that don't do
special things that might particularly
attract public interest so you need to
be aware of that it's not prohibited by
the law I'm not saying it's unlawful to
do it what I'm saying is government
advice is to avoid as far as possible
during pre-election that's those sorts
of issues uh thank you Mr quails that
doesn't help at all I don't think it's
relevant because any any issue that
might come uh relating to this would be
after the election it would be the new
Council that would
um
Mr Dodson yes
sorry I just want to members to to fully
understand the advice of Mr Winslow was
that we would publish in April
foreign if we can't publish until it's
been approved by Council then and
Council wasn't meeting before the
election it would then be statutory
annual on the 18th of May so that the
next available date
would be
the 19th of May which would be a month's
delay I'm only making sure that members
are absolutely clear on what they're
voting on in the implications of it
thank you thank you I'll now I'll now
put no
the the debate's completed I'll now put
the motion uh uh to to the vote those
um uh yeah Miss bird
um I assume that recorded vote was
seconded
yeah okay uh would you call the roll
please those info favor say for or agree
those against say against those abstain
inside abstain
please continue
[Music]
um
um against
his channel
against
um
[Music]
four
Council flicker
at four
thank you
that's the hole against
because the login
full please Tara
Morgan
against
four
suspectively
cancer stamp
four
Stevens
cancer steps
Uncle Ramstein
that's just right four
against
four
okay
[Music]
um that that's therefore carried thank
you members and the next motion can be
motion two councilor Lagan councilor
Lagan 10B motion two
sorry
um
sorry Mr chairman sorry um uh yeah right
okay yeah motion two is the council
returns to an open door policy from 9am
to 4 P.M daily Monday to Friday and has
a fully star front desk presence that
can direct physicists to officers who
can assist with residence inquiries
um I haven't put a preamble in here but
I just want to add a little bit as a
preamble is that I'm not asking for
every officer to come back into the
building I'm asking for maybe like an
ACL type of ECC type of structure where
there's people available to help direct
and pass on to officers who may be in
the building or may be contacted or by
teams or by telephone so that's the
intent of the motion
Mr Holmes
thank you chairman and thank you for the
motion it'd be useful for us to set out
um uh the options available to members
how we actually operate now so I'll
invite Mrs Green to set out how it works
um to give you that information before
you perhaps decide on the motion itself
so Mrs Green please
thank you members um
but I'd like to reassure members that we
do currently deliver a face-to-face
service for our residents who aren't
able to access our Digital Services and
that service is delivered from 10 to
four every day and is resourced by
customer services advisor who is able to
deal with most inquiries
whilst we do encourage members of the
public to make appointments we are able
to deal with and callers to the office
and we would never turn anybody away
what we do have is a fairly strong
Channel shift approach which means that
if we do have a visitor to the office
that we would try and encourage them to
use Digital Services however our
officers would never turn anybody away
and as I said the desk is manned from
ten to four every day
um I hope um if it's okay members I'd
just like to give a little bit of
background to our current approach
so our current customer service to
Residents is being delivered as a
digital first or self-service approach
which was a really key part of the 2019
transformation program and we brought in
significant investment in technology to
make it easier for customers and
residents to access online services
we've invested in improvements to our
website which remains ongoing
we've increased our online forms to
enable customers to contact us 24 7. we
have a program of business and process
improvement work to ensure that we're
able to provide the most efficient and
effective services to our residents and
businesses
in July 2022 members of the strategy and
resources committee endorse a number of
key principles and for our emerging
customer strategy which will be coming
forward to members for consideration and
one of those key principles was
encouraging access to services using the
most efficient and effective
cost-effective channels
that was promoting and encouraging
self-service or supportive access to
online services providing the telephone
service for those that are unable to
access online services and ensuring a
face-to-face service is available for
those customers who need a greater
degree of support and for home digital
or telephone services are not
appropriate
and the current customer service is
being delivered to reflect that key
principle
our face-to-face service currently
mirrors the operation the hours of
operation of our telephone service which
is between 10 and 4. and during that
time it's staffed by a fully trained
customer services officer who will deal
with any callers to the office whether
they have an appointment or not
between the hours of 8 30 to 10 and
after 4 our customer services advisors
will prioritize dealing with online
inquiries to ensure that there is a
prompt response to all customers
regardless which access Channel they
choose to use whether it be telephone
face-to-face or digital
um are really successful digital first
approach means that most customers
Contact Us online and at the moment is
around about 92 percent and there's
around eight percent that then contact
us by telephone
but we do recognize that we have a small
number of residents for whom digital and
telephone contact is not appropriate and
we do recognize this and we continue to
provide that in-person service for
customers who need the extra help
to ensure the most appropriate support
is available we do encourage customers
that want to meet face to face and who
need an appointment to contact us first
so that Arrangements can be made in
order that they can deal with the most
relevant officer however as I've said
our customer service staff are always
available to provide advice and guidance
to any callers to the office and if if
the member of the Public's inquiry can't
be dealt with the first point of contact
we would then triage that inquiry with
to the case officer who would then make
contact with the customer directly to
resolve the inquiry and this is the way
that the council have worked for many
years we've never
operated a service where customers can
walk in and speak to members of of to
offices
what we do do is we ensure that any
urgent issues are always dealt with
immediately
so somebody for example who is homeless
who had no accommodation for the night
we would always deal with that inquiry
there and then
since reopening our reception area and
the types of inquiries that we get
remain very similar to the types of
inquiries that we previously received
and these were customers dropping off
forms or documents or coming to us for
further supplies of recycling sacks and
those type of inquiries are being dealt
with by our customer services team
other inquiries we will deal with and we
do have we do attempt to deal with all
inquiries at the first line at a first
point of contact
one of the differences that has changed
since
um since covid is that prior to covid we
did receive a high number of callers to
the office relating to benefits and
council tax
and and what we did is we did have one
of our revenues and benefits officers
that was available every day to deal
with those inquiries because we did have
a high number
however because of covid and we've we
have found that customers have moved
online and in fact particularly with
council tax and benefits we have found
that those inquiries are now
predominantly dealt with either online
or via telephone
um
this is very similar to what we've seen
with wider benefits so and most DWP
benefits now you have to claim either
online or via telephone so this is
something that customers have become
used to
we've when we reopen the reception area
we did make provision for a revenues and
benefits officer to be available in the
office to if necessary to deliver that
same level of service
but in fact that even though we've had
offices in that service hasn't been
needed and we've actually only had one
member of the public that we've needed
to make an appointment with to deal with
their inquiry because all of those
inquiries are now being dealt with
mostly by telephone or online
um we to give you sorts of Statistics
prior to covid we would have seen around
17 customers per day about inquiries for
their council tax or their benefits
since reopening in April and because of
the channel shift we've actually only
one and seen one customer who's needed a
face-to-face appointment
so the referring to the overall numbers
of visitors so the numbers of visitors
remains quite low an average of around
10 customers per day are coming in to
see us and as I said they're for more
General inquiries dropping off forms and
inquiring about recycling sacs
the majority of people that come to come
to the council offices are actually to
see our partner organizations such as
Citizens advice Bureau Department work
and pensions or the police
we do have a system of managing access
because we do have multiple partners
that we now work with and we did
introduce that and that access jointly
with Partners
um and we have recently reviewed that
and the general feedback from Partners
is the current system works well so when
a member of the public arrives for an
appointment the department work or
pensions or they've come and see the
citizens advice Bureau those partner
organizations will take responsibility
for their own customers so they'll come
and meet and greet them
um and customers can come into the
entrance Lobby and the relevant Partners
able to to then deal with their own
customers
this hasn't presented any problems and
we have received no formal complaints
today about the current arrangements and
as I said we have reviewed this current
situation with with partners and the
feedback is generally that it's working
very well
we are currently working with one modern
partnership Partners
um to develop a community Hub and we
have a working group that is looking at
that with the aim to provide support for
our most vulnerable residents and to
support digital inclusion which is a
really key part
um updates on the progresses in this
this initiative are being reported via
the one modern partnership group and
that will include include a review of
how our reception space is being used by
partners
additionally any resource requirements
to support the Hub will also be
identified through this project and will
be brought back to members for a
decision
it's also proposed that face-to-face
services are included within the remit
of our customer strategy engagement with
members
in summary we wish to reassure members
that we are currently delivering a
face-to-face service for our residents
who are unable to access Digital
Services and that service is being
delivered from ten to four every day and
is being resourced by one of our
customer services advisors who is able
to deal with callers to the office
there has historically been very little
footfall in the early part of the day
and then the current service does mirror
our existing telephone service
and appointments can and have been made
to meet with the public outside of our
normal opening times from 10 till 4 so
if we do have a resident that wants to
have an appointment with us outside of
those times then that can be
accommodated indeed
um regularly years
okay
um sorry
counselor stilts
I didn't realize you finished I'm sorry
thank you Mr chairman hola Mrs Green
doesn't get complaints I'm sure there's
many many people in this chamber that
does
um
all our doors still that they are locked
because the amount of people especially
people that are slightly confused woke
up find a locked door and walk away
again they don't look for a bell to ring
and the person behind the desk doesn't
look up to see if there's someone there
um I actually think you know seeing as a
Town Council can open their doors and
anyone can walk in and talk to them we
are a district council why are we not
giving our residents the same we have
elderly residents we have confused
residents we have residents that cannot
use sorry we have residents that cannot
use the electronic systems
you know we need to be catering for
everyone and anybody that goes onto our
website that tries to find something
well no it's a Minefield so um that's my
thoughts on this thank you Council fluka
thank you thank you chairman um yeah I
mean it was to be honest it was quite
well first of all can I start by
thanking Miss green uh for returning my
personal and private property last night
thank you
um tell me it was quite refreshing to
come to the council offices uh this
morning not have to ring a bell or bang
on the window and and the doors open and
come in I mean my simplistic mind
thought that this motion was apart from
other things to do with an open door
policy
um a few weeks ago when we had that cold
period I came into the council offices
and to a working group meeting and I've
I met two elderly ladies in the in
between the two doors and uh and they
both look absolutely Frozen and I said
and who were you waiting for and they
said more than District Council so I
said have you pressed the bell and she
said yes we found the bill and we
pressed it but we've been here about 10
minutes dear and uh so I went in I let
myself well I let myself in via the
other door because I couldn't get let in
because I couldn't attract the attention
and the person who uh who was on
reception so quick round the side let
myself in and looking at these ladies I
decided chairman to let them in and told
them to sit in the waiting area that I
think cab used there's a couple of seats
there
um I think one had tried to phone the
council and couldn't get any
satisfaction with making an appointment
uh and and the other one had decided to
accompany our friends for the sole
purpose of collecting some pink sacks
but nevertheless they've been trapped
outside in the cold for about eight
minutes
um tell me my feeling is is that it's
not really acceptable you know we've had
some in-depth conversations tonight
tonight it feels like tonight
um with regards to you know DDA
compliance and making sure that we look
after everybody in the community it
doesn't feel very it doesn't make me
feel very comfortable seeing people
standing outside the council offices
um I think actually from what my screen
says is that once you get through the
doors you can see somebody between 10
and 4 o'clock because there's always
somebody there you know I think we just
need you know that is the front of house
that is for Malden District Council you
walk up the steps and the doors are
locked you know I think maybe we should
have a
um I'm sure councilor nuns remind you
that I've had my three minutes but so
but I just think we should make it look
more welcoming I am a great advocate of
Channel shift and I I think Miss green
and her team should be commended on the
championship but we do have this small
minority of people that you know sadly
will disappear out the system probably
in the next 10 years that don't use the
internet they don't use those sort of
facilities and they like to come into
the offices like those two ugly ladies
so I'm sure it was part of their day of
making their day probably talking to
somebody other than each other so maybe
Miss green could sort of take away some
of that and think well maybe we should
work towards having the doors open
between ten to four thank you thank you
councilor Morgan
uh yeah thank you Mr chairman um I have
a lot of sympathy with this motion I've
got a number of people who've come here
and thought they've sort of like the
Mary Celeste and can't find anybody to
help them however I'm just wondering
whether a straightforward motion like
this in this in this body is the best
way of dealing with it we've we've seen
the officers stating that there's a
customer engagement strategy at work and
various other very difficult matters
need to be dealt with with people
working from home and every other thing
and now that I know the lesson R is the
committee that's responsible for looking
into the domestic Arrangements should we
not put this to SNR just for a report
and to come back to come back to council
Council Spencer yeah I just want to say
that I don't think it's always about
thank you I don't think it's always
about the people who can't access
Services sometimes there are some
queries which are just not suitable for
an online form and when we're assessing
the numbers of people coming to Us
online
what we're not counting in in that is
that thing in human nature where you
just give up and you don't come forward
at all so I think you always have to be
careful with Statistics like this and
about what they actually mean I'm going
to say something really controversial
because it's what I truly believe but I
I believe that we should have a customer
services team back in the office I'm
sorry I don't agree with with not having
them here and I think that actually
having a really open friendly and
helpful reception desk is a mark of a
truly efficient and and good
forward-looking organization I don't
think that to be forward-looking we've
all got to disappear behind computer
screens thank you
counselor white then councilor Fleming
and then Council a leader thank you
sorry thank you Mr I have to say that we
actually have the best
um customer services team
um anywhere the the phone service is
absolutely brilliant and in fact I
always use them to speak to officers or
anybody else um they're really really
good
um we I'm a bit surprised this is here
because we've
um already started discussing this as
strategy and resources committee
um and although I'm in favor of
um members of the public being seen by
officers this is something that we need
to Resource
um it needs lots of resources and we
need to work out where the money's
coming from and how we're going to fund
it
um so I think that we need to bring this
to the stressian resources committee and
I'm happy to propose that I do this as
chairman I don't know how we can alter
the amendment to put that in there I'm
not too sure but it needs further work
to move it to SNR okay yeah so I propose
them we really Amendment and send it to
SNR is that is that seconded councilor
Fleming I think next
thank you cheb um I actually support
this motion it's that saying isn't it my
door's always open that's the saying my
doors are always open and I'm afraid the
impression we give here is that our door
is not always open I accept that uh
residents are you know in need of revs
and Benz can go online or telephone but
there's a cost to that you know some
people actually can't afford to use the
Internet or or their phone they could
they can't afford the data you you know
that from you know there are schemes for
those in need to buy
um you know more data and that's that's
the point is that we shouldn't be
putting barriers up I actually think
that the reception desk should be fully
staffed from nine till five or even six
and the doors should be open people
shouldn't be locked out they shouldn't
have to press a button thank you
councilman
chairman are we having a break soon
chairman uh no not for us
sorry okay well I've just judging you
through a few things down um the excess
um the
comments I get back is can't be bothered
to contact to ring the council nobody
does anything can't get in phones are
always busy waste of time time at least
if they get hold of a counselor you do
something for us and also cancer
Fleming's totally right we've only only
had to watch the news that all um like
O2 Vodafone all those price Rises are
coming in I think is it this year
they're going to hike the prizes up
prices up and people aren't going to
have access to be able to do everything
online and no disrespect I'm getting
that little bit older and sometimes it
is I know it's hard to believe chairman
but sometimes sometimes it's hard for me
I'd rather speak to somebody because you
don't always get it first time and if
you put a form in that form you cannot
always be responded to straight away we
should be open we should be welcoming
the leaders speech last night which I
thought should have been back budget but
it was about other things actually
turned around and set it back
communities putting our people first
well we're not putting our people first
are we at the moment chairman and and I
don't support the amendment I don't
think it should go to SNR it's quite
straightforward
proposal and I think the people who've
come to attend this meeting the
councilors who could attend should make
the decisions
councilor Thompson
um thank you chairman
um
I actually think what's most important
is that people who do want to walk in
and have access actually do have access
for what they came from not to make an
appointment to come back again and the
difficulty is resourcing that and have
officers from every department just on
hand waiting to come and talk to people
that they aren't expecting but I
absolutely take councilor fluka's point
and I'm actually wondering if is there
some reason why the doors can't allow
people in to uh to a waiting area that's
inside where they can ring the bell and
get whichever of our partners they want
I mean you know is that a problem
because it seems half a dozen chairs in
reception please come in press a bell
and
sit down sounds like a way forward as
any rate while we wait for things to go
through committees and what have you
because it's still February thank you
oh thank you chairman I mean it seems to
be basically an operational matter
um
the wording here is a bit uh
about from what fully staffed front desk
means I think we would understand that
there's somebody on the desk all the
time
um in which case this shouldn't be in
this problem about the doors being shut
the doors should be open all the time
whether whether there's a whole backup
team on site there to talk to people is
it is a resource matter but
um there's Elders please can direct
visitors to offices who can assist
um I would like to think that that would
enable somebody who
um
can't use it uh interest internet
um who wants to speak to somebody could
be
um put on an Internet contact with an
officer in the reception area in other
words somebody who can't use the
internet or doesn't have access will be
able to use it with the support of the
officer who is Manning the
um the reception desk but I don't know
whether that is actually
um down at the moment whether that is
thought about but
um it comes down to operational matters
as far as I can see
um
Mrs Green wants to answer
or make a comment Mrs Green thank you
chairman
um with regards to being able to contact
UM officers in reception digitally yes
we have set that up so if a member of
the public comes in and they need to
speak to an officer then we do have
teams set up so that members of public
can if necessary speak to the officers
with regards to the access members may
have seem to be coming in today that
we've actually got a sofa that is in
reception that wasn't in there up until
recently
and what we're looking at is we're
looking at being able to exactly as
members have suggested reviewing how the
customers come into us our partners are
still very keen to take responsibility
for managing their own customers however
what we're looking at is is whether or
not we can make it work so that the
customers can still ring the bell in
terms of letting the partners know that
they're here but actually allowing them
to come in and sit and wait until their
appointment so we're just exploring that
with Partners at the moment and as I say
as you'll see there's a sofa in there to
enable us to start to do that
councilor Stevens then councilor
Shaughnessy and then the leader oh
councilor passenger sorry
thank you chair
I don't understand why it's so hard I
mean councilor Thompson just said it
just opened the door I've arrived the
door is shut out yes eventually I'd
assessed that there's a bell over there
or something but I'm looking at the
person on the desk and sort of waving my
arms around and trying to attract
attention
I'm immediately put it off because the
door didn't open and then when I did
come in the person was a bit sort of
what do you want I want the doll to be
welcome and somebody to go good morning
how can I help you I don't think we need
to send it to SNR or anywhere else to do
that it's just let's do it can we just
agree to do that now please thank you
Council Shaughnessy
thank you chairman I'm rapidly becoming
that old lady confused by the Bells
that those bells should absolutely go
we have to have a complete open door
policy
um one perhaps two people welcoming on
the desk that is definitely the way to
go and I think we need to pass this
today thank you thank you Council of
Passenger and then Melinda thank you Mr
chairman
I completely agree with um councilor
Stevens and councilor Shaughnessy I mean
basically it's a point of contact issue
as far as I'm concerned I think as you
come to this building the door should
open you should be able to go to a desk
which you can and there is somebody
there and they should be able to direct
you so I think it's perfectly simple all
we want off the doors to be open and for
people to be able to access the building
and actually speak to somebody and then
get directed to the help they need they
may have to come back which is perfectly
reasonable I think you make an
appointment you know you you can't
expect people just to be in the building
to to facilitate every single inquiry
but I do think you should be able would
have a point of contact and those doors
should be open thank you thank you
um the the penultimate speaker the
leader before councilor Lagann sums up
leader
um thank you chairman uh well I've
listened to the debate and it's clear
there's some real um feelings within the
chamber regarding members of the public
being able to access our offices uh nine
to four instead of ten till four having
the open door policy
um I actually have um always been one of
those of um I'm sure Mrs Green will say
that regarding older persons and um I'm
not in any way saying they're not on the
internet but a large number of people
perhaps don't like the digital that's
why I was very keen to ensure this
council did make sure we cover
all our customers in terms of
inclusivity how we have access to them
well I would say I think where councilor
Miss White was coming from and um very
clear because SNL has been looking at it
and a draft there is a customer
engagement strategy a customer strategy
being looked at now a draft of that can
go to SNR and together I think it's very
important members know about the one
Malden District and the community Hub
that Miss green has spoken about
um indeed and that may actually
influence people and that part of that
strategy should be about engagement with
our public and see what they want
actually and feel they want and also
members so chairman there's a mood in
the chamber which is very clear but I I
can see uh councilor White's coming from
and I'm sure that will happen anyway I
think that should happen anyway a draft
policy strategy which has been spoken
about should go to SNR together with an
update on what is happening regarding
the one Malden partnership and the
Community Hub thank you counselor please
thank you Chan you'll be very pleased
I'm sure when everybody at the top table
that this is my last bit um we're only
asking to have a door open
and what um Miss White has actually said
all the work that's been done is really
good you know the channel shift was
thrown on us transformation was thrown
on us you know and you've responded to
that there's not there's not an ounce of
problem with that it's just you know
we all people have said I think the
chamber everyone said that you don't get
the complaints we do
because they can't access you to get to
the complaint so you get it you know and
we've got a lot of bridges to build with
people we've got a lot of ways of being
inclusive rather than exclusive and it's
astonishing what you can do you know I
remember pre-cover coming up and just
walking in the door-to-door open you
know and that gives me an access point
there's no barriers there I'll go
straight up to a counter and I see or
somebody and I got some support
and I had to come back some on occasions
and was directed to other locations I
don't see I think we're making it bigger
than Ben Hur and I can't see the point
The Logical expense needed to refer to
another committee so if that resolution
goes through it should fail in my
opinion but it's down to members to make
that decision it the only difference
that we're asking because you said um
it's like someone's on the on the desk
anyway is epidural yeah that's it yeah
thank you okay
um I I have uh an amendment uh that it
be referred to SNR but my feelings is
the consensus in the count the chamber
is that that isn't necessary do you
still wish to proceed with that Miss
White uh sorry uh no chairman I think
we've clarified it I actually thought
that Council Legend was asking for
something totally different but now I
understand what he's asking for no I'll
withdraw my um a minute thank you um
I think I think you're going to get
everybody in agreement
um
members agree that motion agreed thank
you anybody against
no thank you very much we'll then go on
to the next one which you can see one a
councilor fluka but 10 c1a is not
required account we can now come to
Council of fluka do you wish to proceed
with that
that motion
um
seeing people
sanity
Services
by saying this when I joined the council
12 years ago
um when I joined the council 12 years
ago there was a process there was a
process in place where members were
invited into the various departments to
see how they worked and I can I can
remember going along to Miss Green's
department and and and she and her staff
then were explaining how revs and bends
worked and I think I had to have several
meetings in room 8 afterwards because I
never did get it but I'm a serious
smiling but she was most helpful and and
I think in many ways chairman it's the
same as housing
um you know I I feel as though members
you know don't really see what the
housing department does how much hard
workload they do
um and I can remember also going to uh
the housing department
foreign
yeah so I can also remember going to the
housing department with I'm sure lots of
people in chamber will remember Mr Gala
uh who proceeded Mr sword and uh and uh
yeah and they showed us how it all
worked and what they did and everything
else and I do hope chairman that when
the new Administration comes in in May
that we maybe pick up on that because I
feared so a lot of members don't
understand you know what's going on
behind the scenes in this councilman you
know I start by saying saying that the
unwavering and tenacious hard work of
the senior specialist coordinator
housing and his and his team he leads is
recognized and commended upon they do a
huge amount of work and I'm pleased that
Mr Johnson is here to hear that actually
um just to put some background to this
on the 10th of February the
district-wide immediate housing need
visitors was was as followed there were
over 1100 applicants singles couples and
families on the housing register with a
further 80 applicants waiting to be
processed by comparison between 2008 and
the first lockdown there were 750
applicants so you can see chairman you
can sorry 750 applicants in in the
registered before uh the lockdown so you
can see how the figures of meat moved
um
sadly chairman they were currently 91
homeless applications 50 families and 41
singles this is the highest number since
our records began and there are 20
applicants you know chairman I've only
got the data on the 10th of February and
I'm sure Mr swords will update it and I
do hope it's dropped so significantly
but I suspect it hasn't
um there are 20 applicants families
couples in singly singles currently
nightly paid
temporary accommodation outside of the
district the furthest away on that date
being Pizza Bar
um I mean obviously there's you know
there's a huge amount of money involved
in in painfulness and
and I think everybody recognize this
chairman that nationally their their
there is a huge problem with
homelessness and people on the homeless
register and the housing register
um you know we can we can talk forever
about this this Council does very well
in providing social and affordable
housing but it clearly isn't enough
um having done some background searches
and looking at them
oh looking at um so I was I was just
saying chairman this Council does a
marvelous job in providing this
affordable and social uh uh housing
through the the the the process of our
local development plan
um but when you look at other councils
and you look at the figures Pro rata in
relation to the number of houses they
have the number of residents they have
you know we do look as though we're in a
slightly worse position than our
contemporaries and I think it's a long
time since you know it's certainly you
know I've looked at homeless policies of
this Council and and I do know
um chairman and and
um I'll I'll speak carefully but I do
know chairman the housing department are
looking at a scheme which could address
some of these issues
um so chairman of my motion is is really
quite straightforward and and that is
that this Council based on those figures
and where we are nationally that we
declare a homeless crisis I mean this is
this is very very serious I can't
remember
um the last time we debated these
figures it was a long long time ago and
I remember being quite shocked then and
we need to get behind our homeless our
housing team chairman and
my understanding from speaking to
members of that team is they seem to be
under-resourced now
far be it to me to say that we should
increase the establishment of this
Council but they do seem to be
under-resourced in relation to the
amount of work they do and I know how
hard they were you know I've been
working with them over premises in South
Minster which we've used in the past and
it keeps dipping in and out and I'm
hoping that we can dip back in again but
Kevin my motion is terminate the council
declares a homeless crisis and resolves
to agree that the next meeting the
council the corporate leadership team
presents an updated strategy to reduce
homeless in the district which I'm not
that's my motion but I would expect and
I would expect chairman that when that's
brought forward
um the reviewer Department's done
particularly with regards to resourcing
to see whether or not they really do
need some more resources my gut feeling
is Chairman whether it's short-term or
not they do need that and obviously I'll
send it to what the officers sell I'm
mainly yeah yeah I was I was going to
ask you if if you are not so
prescriptive about no no no
can you know me better than most and and
I'm very open to any suggestion you
might make I might not agree with it but
I think that we've got to be careful too
I've always I've text Mr Holmes already
about motion three and timing but yeah I
look let's but let's do it we owe it to
the homeless you know we're just about
to spend 250 000 pounds to play
equipment and here we go with homeless
people in bed and breakfast in
Peterborough yes sorry to sound like a
socialist but I think I'm turning into
one
um
I always thought you was
um can okay
do do you agree to not be so
prescriptive with about reporting to the
next council meeting because that may
help you yeah look I I I I'm I'm sort of
I'm sort of happy to amend that but what
I want to do is look look we have proved
it to ourselves last night that if we
set a challenging timeline we can
deliver quickly and a few is an
objectively this is a slightly different
issue I think chairman think of those
people in bed and breakfast this evening
in Peterborough that's how urgent is
it's as urgent as the corporate plan but
chairman I agree we need to do this work
I mean I I'm quite happy if if officers
give me a steer I'm quite happy to amend
it uh or if someone gives me a steer
can I can I can I call on Mr Holmes yeah
yeah
all right thank you chairman um so I
think Mr Holmes that he did agree to not
be so prescriptive I did hear that too
Jim uh firstly I'd like to uh invite two
officers to come forward who actually
takes us through the details so just do
a bit of administration and swap over a
couple of officers so I'm going to
invite Mr swords and Mr Gayla Ford who
will go through a response for you we
have looked at the Preamble we've also
uh the motion and obviously we'll give
some up-to-date information for members
ahead of your your decision
um I want to reassure members that we
are very much looking at resourcing and
obviously again through the decisions of
council and the changes to the structure
for that identifiable housing team and I
think you're right we probably will
identify resource issues in that there
are more things we can do um but
obviously that does need resource so
very mindful of that and the structure
changes that we're making will actually
help strengthen that housing team
um however I think I now hand over Mr
Gayla who's going to perhaps first deal
with the Preamble some of the issues
raised and then give you some more
up-to-date information
okay thank you and firstly thank you for
the kind comments regarding the senior
officers within the housing team they do
indeed work extremely hard to try and
deliver the housing duties to Modern
residents Breeze of reference are broken
down the Preamble into a series of Four
Points just to help
reference those more clearly so the
first point was that on the 10th of
February 2023 the housing needs register
had
1144 applicants with a further 80
waiting to be processed and by
comparison in 2008 up to First lockdown
there were 750 applicants
so the high numbers of applicants on the
council's housing register actually
reflect the lack of affordable housing
that we've got within the district
and the drivers for that lack of
affordable accommodation include a lack
of approved Housing Development within
the district we're getting a loss of
private rented stock as private
landlords leave the area
there's an increase in competition for
our own local Housing Resource and
that's driven by competition with
central government and also neighboring
local authorities who are trying to
compete in in this area for private
rented stock
we have an inability to financially
compete with private landlords as well
due to the restrictive local housing
allowance rates and the spending power
of other local councils and we also have
a lack of larger family size dwellings
in District
and as such people that are on our
waiting list are having to wait longer
for those properties to become available
there was also a reference to 91 people
currently on our um homeless people
currently on their register and this is
made up of 50 families 41 singles
and this is the highest number since our
records began
um just to try and put that in context
um the total number of homeless
approaches that the council have
remained similar over the last couple of
years so for 21 to 22 there were 650 for
22 to 23 there were 682 for this Current
financial year it's currently 448 but
we're missing quarter four data so we're
expecting it to be relatively similar
but again this is due to a lack of
properties but this time both interim
accommodation and more settled
accommodation and as such homeless
applicants on our housing register are
having to wait longer to access
properties
the 20 applicants that are placed
outside of District the furthest away
being Peterborough
um I do think this is um
a trend that's developed due to again
lack of affordable accommodation and
interim accommodation in District now
our officers have to try and Source the
most affordable properties wherever they
can and hence the reason why we're
having to go further afield this is
unfortunately a trend I think will
continue but we can certainly hope that
if affordable housing rates in in the
district increase we can reduce it and
try and keep more people in our local
area
and the last comment
when when I when I reference our
contemporaries and just to try and give
you some sort of context if I look for
example at Epping Forest where I was a
former employee
Epping Forest has a very large Council
housing stock it has land aheads and
it's trying to develop all of that if
you go through everything for us now it
looks completely different to what it
was back in 20 2008
um but it also has a very large housing
team there's over 30 offices there all
working across different areas of the
council
um this is also the case but to a
slightly different extent for Castle
point and Brentwood councils both of
which have their own housing stock and
land assets and actively try and use
them to the benefit
by contrast we're not a stock holding
Authority we rely on Housing Association
Partners we've got extremely limited
land assets
um but we have got local development
occurring Watford District Council is
probably a similar Council to us in
terms of their housing setup and the
housing team numbers
so while
appreciating that all councils have
their own challenges
now I wouldn't say we're unique but we
do have more than specific challenges
that we're trying to overcome
what we do have and maybe this might
sound biased but I believe we have a
very proactive housing team and
like-minded officers across the council
that are really trying to find
Innovative Housing Solutions for the
residents
um what I would suggest
um it's mentioned the term homeless
crisis I would suggest a more app term
would be a housing crisis which takes
into account all the services that
housing provide
um lastly I would just comment that we
do have an active uh homeless rough
sleeper and housing strategy because
recently extended to 2025 and that was
agreed that strategy and resources on
the 6th of the 10th and that underpins
the work
for various Council officers the current
housing strategy contained 42 actions
and we did regret them in the end
um what I can tell you is that 17 of
those actions are now completed in
business as usual 12 of those are
considered Amber and they're part of
ongoing discussions and work 11 of those
are considered to be at risk and there's
various reasons for that
and there's two that are waiting grading
um so bearing in one we already have a
relevant and active uh homeless housing
strategy I would suggest
um happy to work on addendum to
incorporate new challenges uh bring that
back to um whichever committee uh
members feel fit and just one more point
of assurance
um it's not just Housing Services that
try and assist our residents in their
hour of need we've also got the
excellent the Strategic theme lead for
Community uh does with the public
private and voluntary sectors uh and
also we've got the work that the
commercial team do in conjunction with
the housing team to try and bring
forward some of those innovative
solutions so that's just a snapshot of
where we are just I hope you found it
useful
Mr swords
thank you chair um thank you members
uh Damien's obviously given some very
good facts and figures and I don't want
to drag this on any longer four members
because you've got a lot to get through
today but um I just wanted to just
clarify really a couple of points um
those out of district is actually since
those last figures a couple of weeks ago
that's actually gone out now to 23
families now outside of the district the
numbers on the housing register roughly
are still the same
um with our local housing needs
assessment in 2021 the Target that they
recommended that was set in it was that
we needed it every year 209 affordable
units
this year and last year for example last
year in total we achieved 109 and this
year in total to date we have achieved
123.
so you can see members that just over
the last two years were actually nearly
200 units short on what that is being
recommended which has an impact then on
everybody that is homeless or on the
housing register
and just last little bits of facts I
just wanted to say because I think this
is quite important for members to
understand
with regards to the housing register in
bangs see up to Ben's eye so that's high
housing need to extreme housing need we
currently have 102 families
102 in band C to a
of those 102 70 families need a
three-bedroom property
and in this financial year to date we've
only had 16 three bedroom properties to
be able to allocate to them
and we also need
um we've got through 21 families that
need a four bedroomed property in those
bands
and we've not had any four bedroom
properties this year in fact I can't
remember the last time we had a four bed
I think it was a couple of years back
and we also have one family needs five
bed we only have one five bed property
in the district that is occupied and has
been occupied for some considerable
period of time
so just to reiterate really what Damian
has said you know we are trying in the
housing department it is very difficult
there's lots of factors as Damian has
mentioned
um and you know what we're trying to do
is not just deal with those people that
are coming in at the front end but
strategically we're trying to look at
other options and the Strategic housing
board with members that we meet with on
a quarterly basis they're aware of some
of those potential options that we're
looking at and indeed you know we're
very shortly to hopefully take some
reports on options especially in dealing
with temporary accommodation to I
believe it's strategy and resources if
we can get all the information in on
time for the next meeting so we're
dealing at the front end and we're
equally trying to deal with it as a
bigger picture you know across the
district long term but it is very
difficult for us and I've been here 15
years and I can honestly say it's
definitely definitely the hardest I've
ever seen in the 15 years thank you
thank you Mr swords Council Stevens
thank you obviously for any person who
is homeless or about to be homeless they
are having a crisis but I'm very wary of
using the expression crisis I think if
we're going to do that sort of thing as
a council we need to have some sort of
terms of reference around all a
definition of what is a crisis what do
we do about the crisis how much budget
do we give the crisis otherwise it's
just a label it didn't make any
difference I don't think it achieves
anything in itself and how long do we
keep on going on with this crisis do we
wait till there are no homeless people
before we stop the crisis I just would
want to see something set out in terms
of what the labeling it a crisis would
achieve otherwise there seems no point
in doing that thank you thank you Mr
Holmes
thank you Jim I think we also know there
is a national issue here it's not
something we're dealing with a local
level and there's not a magic answer
this all the good work that the officers
are doing in housing is to address the
problem you have so I do have some
concerns about calling it a crisis
because as you say you need to resolve a
crisis and it's not as straightforward
because it's a national problem sit
every day you see it in the news so I
think yeah perhaps we do need to change
the language of that but obviously what
what the team has outlined you is the
proactive work they're actually doing to
give you that level of reassurance
um and we do have a strategy and that
could be reviewed I think there's a
suggestion that could be added too so
maybe the answer is through the strategy
and resources committee we bring
something to strengthen the existing
strategy Channel
yeah yeah
thank you chairman
um I know that the two officers who have
spoken are actually working from their
heart and not just from their heads I
know that I've known John saws for a
long time and uh and I definitely know
that
um but I also would like to bring
everyone down to the wire
um today because
um as a lot of you know I'm the chair of
the leech Memorial Garden or chair of
friends of the village Memorial Garden I
should say apologies
um and from time to time we have had
people sleeping rough in there now my
Posh neighbors have thrown up their
hands in horror
but my husband and I actually speak to
these people offer them our facilities
if they wish to take that up
I also speak from the heart on this like
John and Damien
and I I just wanted to put it out there
that my husband and I have actually
experienced
um you know speaking to these people in
these dire circumstances and they
haven't always been single young men
by any means thank you thank you madam
councilor stem
chairman councilor Morgan had his hand
up before me so I'll give what he did
you just didn't see him so I'll give way
all right Council Morgan
uh yeah thank you Mr chairman I I sort
of have to say I fully agree with uh
cancer Stevens there and I'm just
wondering why we're actually here and
the officers have been taken away from
their desks to discuss this just as far
as I put my brief experience with with
the officers is that they're not lost
already any illusion how serious the
housing crisis is this this district and
they're doing as far as I can see their
level best to do it and to sort of say
that we should therefore
announced that there's a housing crisis
to my mind it's almost seems to suggest
that they are somehow falling down on
their job which I think is would be it
would be a great slur on them so I'm
just I'm just really wondering what we
do the officers should be allowed to get
back to doing the Sterling work if I
know they're doing
um they're here they're here today
because I've decreed that we have these
motions
um uh
uh today uh and it saves them turning up
to an evening meeting
um councilor stamp yeah thank you um if
we take on board everything councilor
Morgan said at this meeting then I don't
actually think we need to have any
members we just leave everything to the
officers because we are elected to
scrutinize and bring motions and areas
of concern that we believe as elected
members but chairman my question is
really and I've had conversations with
John swords he's excellent in Zoe's Dome
Galos everybody said chairman
um but when are these planning
applications are being put forward and
the section 106s are being agreed before
the um reports are coming to planning
chairman why are we not seeing more of
the properties we want all we need as a
district why is it suddenly becoming a
shock because I don't believe it ever
has been a shock we've had these
conversations for months so why are we
not getting these required affordable
homes we're doing 40 in Burnham and
crafts we've got loads of affordable
homes why have we not got five bedrooms
why have we not got four bedrooms
there's loads of applications coming
forward so I would actually ask I'm not
blaming you so please don't say that I
am I'm blaming the authority if there is
or asking the authority to address the
need and there is a national housing
crisis but I agree with um um oh God
keptice Davis I was going to call you
Thompson no I do right sorry but I do
because now it's in my head and but I
don't agree it's a crisis and I think we
have to put it in perspective and I
actually applaud councilor um fluka for
raising it because it's always sat below
the radar at this Authority thank you
um Mr swords thank you chair it's just
an answer to that Council stamp the the
issue that we're kind of facing now
especially with family sort of
accommodation was
um back in 2012 2013 the Strategic
housing market assessment as was then
um it sort of decreed that we really
needed a lot more smaller properties and
that's what we're now seeing coming
through on the Strategic size
predominantly but what I'm also doing is
when I work working with the planning
officers now on pre-applications for
potential schemes you know in the next
year or two years three years whatever
this is where I'm now making sure that
I'm really trying to force that we're
getting Bungalows for older people and
also more family housing that's what I'm
trying to ensure and we do now have the
local housing needs assessment 2021 that
equally says a greater proportion of
larger family homes especially four beds
where we've now got a figure of up to 10
percent on that sort of thing
I was going to say that
blame the Secretary of State's lldp
especially why seriousness that that's
what I was referring to because it we we
did know as as councilors chairman that
that those properties weren't needed and
when those properties came up for one
and two bedrooms we knew they weren't
needed because you had other sites
strategic sites that was developing and
building the map Germany but but
um 12 years ago uh or 10 or 11 years ago
the market was a different Market
capital of wine counselor white
um thank you Mr chairman
um well first of all I'd like to put
forward a slight Amendment
um because and I'll I'll go into why
before I give it
um now I obviously those chair structure
and resources and the members who
proposed this actually sit on my
committee and what I don't quite
understand is that strategy resources
we've done an awful lot of work on a
homeless strategy in it this motion
almost suggests that we've done nothing
um we've worked really closely with the
two is here who speak from their heart
and doing everything they can and we've
been trying to think of so many ways of
housing people
um but this is a national issue this is
not just a Malden issue and in fact
we're doing better than a lot of
authorities in that we don't really have
homeless we have people in temporary
housing it's not ideal and it's not what
we want
but we no but we need to bring this if
it's been homeless and temporary housing
um we have a very tiny amount of
homeless this is sounding like we have
hundreds of homeless people um but but
what I'm saying but what I'm saying is
what I don't understand is and you sit
on stretching resources we've had
confidential reports come to the
committee outlining proposals that we
have in the pipeline absolutely to
resolve this issue and we've put a lot
of resource into it there's continued
resource coming into it and I'm actually
really excited about the project the
main one I'm thinking of but I can't
mention it now because it's confidential
so what I what I think we should be
doing is we should be inviting all
members to the structure resources
particularly the ones who are already on
there and maybe they've missed this
exciting
um proposal and perhaps we can have this
proposal come up and I'll invite all
members this meeting so you can see what
it is there's no point in bringing it to
the next full Council because we won't
be able to discuss it because it has to
be in private confidential so trust me
we are working really really hard on the
homeless we are working really really
hard to provide more of our own housing
and if this proposal comes to being it
could well build many many homes and
what I hope will be in a home Surplus
rather than a home's deficit like every
other authority in the country is so my
amendment is that we continue with the
review that we're already undertaking
and then it comes to the next strategy
and resources in private and
confidential and I'll phone every single
member on this Council to try and insist
that they attend so they can actually
find out what we're doing because we are
working really really hard and this
motion suggests that members in the
offices are doing nothing to resolve
these issues so my amendment is is it
comes to strategy and resources well
that's how I'm reading it that's how I'm
reading it um
cancel the hull
thank you chairman thank you for the
speech and let me speak
um I don't know if you know but I take a
lot of these people on
um around the farm and um what I find
it's um really hard because they are
going through crisis and it's really
hard to to keep them up on the straight
and narrow
um but I don't know it's a lot of it's
private confidential what Sue's going
through but if you want what are some
ideas I had to make it easier for the
people that are in private that private
rented because what you find if you get
somebody in private rented they don't
they abuse the place or they don't pay
them in you can't get them out so people
aren't willing to put their private
homes up for rent or invest in renting
so I just wondered if there's any way we
can make it easier so if they don't pay
their rent or if they do wreck the place
they get help you know or we can help
somehow and the second one I've just
I've got an Australian staying with me
in the moment and what she's saying in
their country with their part of the
country where she is in Queensland they
use these containers and make them into
houses as just as temporary
um one they're well insulated they're
easy to put up to move
um they're not expensive
um I don't know with some of the local
farmers or even some of the churches if
you could say could we put one on your
you know and help that in a temporary
way
um
also we've got the big problem a lot of
these houses that people have split up
so you've instead of having one house
they've all want two houses and we've
got one young girl that's gone into a
lovely home just in the new houses just
coming into Malden and somehow they've
all got damp so they've all had to be
moved out of there so that's you know
she said there was about three or four
of them all in the same situation I
don't know why that what that is but she
was really she's been looked after now
but she had to have many weeks in
accommodation but then that was the same
she split up with a husband they've both
got two houses instead of one and that's
quite a lot to deal with so I don't know
we just need some uh you know ideas
really and because I'd be willing to put
some containers up and I'm sure other
people would and this this is not this
is this isn't new I remember 30 years
ago when it was a proposal to deal with
homeless issues a particular counselor
actually died just there during the
council
now now in front in front in front of
you
um
so and I won't I won't say
um what the proposal was at that time
um
but it was similar to the Australian
uh let him go yeah I I
Council of flukey you want to make an
amendment did you yeah thank you
chairman but before I do I refer
councilman white to the first paragraph
of my Preamble and I look forward to her
apology
um and chairman I've never ever
questioned what what Mr Saul's done I've
known him ever since I've come here and
and you know if anybody needs commending
it's him in his department and Mr Gala
and the previous Mr Gay law uh who I
referred to earlier and you know what we
need to do is to get this Council right
behind you now clearly everybody here
now is quite passionate about doing that
but there's 15 members I think that
aren't here tonight or this afternoon on
this morning who really need to be aware
of what you're doing and then they'll
get behind you and hopefully give you
the support that you need and Kevin I
propose that that the uh an amendment
um to my emotion insofar as chairman
that at its meeting of today uh Council
resolves to agree that at a future
meeting of council at a future meeting
the council the corporate leadership
team presents an updated strategy
strategy to reduce homelessness in in
the district I think that's what the
officers have already alluded to and
agreed to and I think that's what Mr
Holmes has as well so I think that
Amendment sits well and and allows us is
that seconded thank you
and uh councilor stilts
thank you Mr chair
um I was going to ask uh Mr Souls a
question and that is we sat at a preact
the other day and when you look at the
pre-apps most of them stop at four
bedroom houses if we know that we need
five bedroom houses why are we not
asking these developers to put
bigger houses into their thing for that
and also when they come forward with
affordable housing for us
oh we actually signed to we need X
number for Air residence rather than
then letting them go to other
people other authorities yeah I know Mr
swords has got that world tied up Mr
swords thank you chairman that
councilors
um so just on the second Point
um yes obviously we make sure through
our legal agreements on those schemes
that we have first let's 100 nomination
rights in fact on a lot of schemes we're
now actually I've been working very
closely with Mr quelch we're actually
trying to enforce and ensure that in
perpetuity but we always have those lets
for residents in the district
um it does become obviously a matter of
negotiation once the housing
associations get on board because they
too would like to work with us because
they want to try and use these
properties as well for Urgent management
moves and we understand that and we try
to work with them on that basis as well
but generally that that's what we're
trying to do with regards to the um the
actual legal planning document 106 on
nominations and the first one I think
was the five bed wasn't it the five
properties
um
yes we do try to look and we do try to
ask
we have to be careful when we're looking
at five bedroom properties because
a lot of our residents it's all around
the issues of local housing allowance
and what we try to ensure is that if we
do look at a large property four bed for
example that it's let as a social rent
property the issues that come into play
there are between then the Housing
Association and the developer when they
are negotiating negotiate what's that
negotiating with all of the housing
associations because they're looking at
price
and the issues that you've got there is
the fact that as an affordable rent
property a Housing Association can
charge a higher rent than they can for a
social rent property but for a social
rent property the ones that we want that
helps people that are on low incomes and
low benefits uh sorry on benefits so
what we tend to try and do is if we do
ask and we have asked and we are getting
some four bedroomed properties through
we make sure under what we call National
design space standards that the
developer builds to that level and that
size so that we're looking at four
bedroomed seven-person properties where
possible so that we can accommodate a
five a family that needs a five bed into
a four bed seven if they're large double
rooms that's how we try to do it because
the danger is if we ask for a five bed
and then later down the line the Housing
Association says we can't charge social
rent on it we can only charge affordable
rents then the problem is it's it's
excluding a lot of people on our housing
register and that's not really the point
and purpose of what we're trying to do
okay thank you thank you
um councilor Flo Carino or um uh a
moment are you also removing the word
crisis which seems to upset one or two
members
um
that was the first thing my friends went
to the left cost out for me thinking
councilor Lagan
thank you chair I'll be quite brief um I
know I've learned a lot
yeah that really Evan thank you very
much indeed I think one thing I've
learned is that time time changes lead
doesn't it from the and what was needed
back then into now and with the ldp
review going on I think it's a key
indicator this certainly gives me
something to to think about should I
stand and be re-elected
um we've we've talked about a lot of
officers and I've not noted down here we
don't have bad offices we just have bad
systems
I think working within the systems and
the constraints that we have
um really does show that the work that's
being done despite all the constraints
that we have but you have let's be
honest and that you have
um it is remarkable so I just want to
say thank you from me because and thank
you turkey councilor fluka
um for bringing this forward because
it's it's something that
I need to get more up to speed with um
and I as I said I've learned an awful
lot today and I appreciate that okay uh
leader uh penultimate speech please uh
thank you very much chairman
um I don't think I need to go over all
the grounds that the officers have said
but I would say I think Mr Holmes has
made it clear about the housing team and
how Something There Will perhaps
indicate resources are required I think
we've heard from Mr Gayla and Mr Source
what's going on I'd just like to add
that to it they are a very hard working
team they are a small team but they're
highly dedicated and I think one of the
issues of course is we are a non-stock
holding Authority so that initially
places us on a an area which is not so
easy to work in we haven't got our
housing ourselves and that disappeared
over well about over 28 years ago and
what I would like to say and bring to
the equation because I do think it needs
to be mentioned as well we're very good
in terms of our initiatives to do with
rust sleeping in fact we're working
being in Partnership there and we did
get an award and I think that needs to
be mentioned as well because there's
another facet to the team going on
regarding
um councilor Stevens I'm grateful to her
and councilor flukens listened because
you've stopped um You by are you saying
that as indicated I think you're
absolutely writing what you've said in
terms of Crisis and that wording should
not be applied regarding councilor
stamps she's correct I've said that
before about the bedrooms in terms of
we've got to think of families not
everyone wants a one or two bedroom
property and that's we've heard from the
officers regarding that issue
um regarding the Strategic housing board
and Council Stevens will know this
because she sits that on with me and
there are some initiatives being
considered there and as the officer said
there would be a report going I believe
that is going to stretch in resources in
the not too far distant future so there
are initiatives being considered and
what I would like to say it's not just
about the situent the officers are in
now in when people are homeless it's
actually there's a tremendous lot of
work that is applied through that very
small team to prevention of homelessness
and that's a very important aspect of
the service if you can prevent
hopelessness occurring that saves you
having greater problems down the road so
I would like to say thank you for all
you're doing in that aspect because
that's a primary task of that housing
team as well and so chairman I I do
leave it there chairman thank you very
much so we've got reports going uh the
addendum that's been applied to the
homelessness and housing strategy that's
already gone through SNR and we're
hearing what Mr Holmes said so I think
we're covering actually off the issues
that councilor fluka has raised I'm sure
we'll agree receive those reports with
interest thank you I think um yes it's
for Council of Folker to sum up now but
I I believe actually his motion has been
achieved
um uh uh if he uh has a report come back
to a future Council that will come back
via SNR anyway Kevin that's definitely
not what I was proposing to no because I
think you know look Jim think about the
corporate plan and how quickly we moved
that forward we're toodling off to
strategy and resources with a world
debated and World rehearsed argument and
and stopping these guys getting on with
it you know getting getting some more
resources to them and moving this all
forward so Tim you know my proposal my
mended motion is on the table and and I
so move chairman yeah okay okay thanks
um uh then again
Chancellor white I thought I seconded it
going to especially in resources and
um everybody could see the confidential
report but if but if it's at any future
meeting it doesn't have to be the next
Council because this can't be pulled
together overnight it's not as simple as
the corporate plan that was that was the
point I was making Council Fluker sorry
amended motion was for a future council
meeting which which which will come via
SNR
which will come virus and art anyway
those in favor
um
uh well that's that's that
there you are members um I'll put that
motion to the vote those in favor oh I
think
no but but she accepted I think yeah
yeah if I might come in as long as it
doesn't have to be at the fixed speed
you can commit future one because I a
lot of this isn't in place yeah
yeah
um
uh those in favor please show
um somebody count
one oh that's interesting
um that motion is is carried uh and it
is now 25 uh to one uh I uh a German
meeting for chairman point of order
please
um Tim and I I presume you're going to
adjourn for lunch and chairman if it's
your if it is your intention to adjourn
for lunch Gemini I'd ask you to adjourn
this meeting sign you die
um I can't stay in this meeting any
longer I've got work commitments
chairman and there are members listening
on uh on YouTube I think is it YouTube
or something like that at the moment who
I won't say they're concerned but
they're interested to hear what you've
decided today
um personally I think this has been a
really good exercise you know we've
spent a lot of time discussing these
emotions and I think there's a lot of
things coming I'm very pleased with
what's happening so am I but you know I
was very much against coming today and
I've had Chef so chairman I've you know
I hate using
I am going to withdraw all of my motions
then thank you thank you
um does that does that just leave
councilor Spencer's one
there's one in confidence oh oh there's
one in confidential
no no I'm a journey for an hour yeah uh
this meeting's adjourned until 22 too
afternoon